RYAN MATSUMOTO:
Cloud Shell Editor
makes it easy for you to run
code from your web browser
and deploy it to the Cloud.
And Google Kubernetes
Engine makes
it easy to deploy,
manage, and scale
your containerized applications
using Google infrastructure.
So you might be
wondering, can I write
the code for my Google
Kubernetes Engine apps
in Cloud Shell Editor?
Yes, you definitely can.
With this Cloud
code integration,
Cloud Shell Editor
gives you the power
to write code for your
Kubernetes application,
test and debug the app locally,
create Google Kubernetes Engine
clusters, and finally deploy
your app to a cluster.
In this video,
we're going to learn
how to use Cloud Shell Editor to
deploy an application to Google
Kubernetes Engine.
Let's go.
First, visit
ide.cloud.google.com
to launch the
Cloud Shell Editor.
On the status bar at the
bottom of your screen,
click Cloud Code.
From the Cloud Code menu,
click New Application,
and then select
Kubernetes Application
for the type of sample app
that we want to create.
After that, we'll get a list
of Google Kubernetes Engine
samples to choose from.
Let's go with the Go
Hello, World option.
Next, select a folder in
your Cloud Shell environment
to save your application
to and give it a name.
If that looks good, click
Create New Application.
Cloud Shell Editor loads the
files for your sample app
into a new workspace.
You can see the list of files
in the Explorer panel located
on the left side of the screen.
Now let's go ahead and
test our app locally.
For this next section, you
will run your application
on a local Kubernetes
cluster in Cloud Shell.
In the top menu, click
Terminal, and then New Terminal.
This opens up a new Cloud
Shell Terminal window
at the bottom of your screen.
In your Terminal,
run Mini Cube Start
to start your local
mini cube cluster.
Once your cluster
is set up, you will
see a confirmation message.
From the Cloud Code menu,
select Run on Kubernetes,
and confirm that you want to
use the mini cube context.
The Output panel
displays the progress
as your app is
built and deployed
to the local mini cube cluster.
Once your app is built,
you can launch it
by hovering over the URL link
displayed in the Output panel
and clicking Open Web Preview.
Congratulations.
If you see this page, that
means you've successfully
run your first app on
Kubernetes using Cloud Code.
Now let's go ahead
and modify the app.
To learn more about
this Hello World app,
you can browse the files
in the Explorer tab.
At a high level, it includes
a Go Hello World web
app in main.go that returns a
templated It's Running response
to all received requests.
There's also a load
balancer service
called Go Hello, World
External in hello.service.YAML
that exposes the app by
describing a Kubernetes
service.
Now let's go ahead
and modify the app.
Select the main.go
file and replace It's
Running with It's Redeploying.
The file saves and
rebuilds automatically.
You can monitor your app's
progress in the Output panel.
This is Cloud Code's Watch mode.
But it's something you
can turn off if you want.
Once your app finishes
building and deploying,
refresh your open tab
to see the updated app.
To analyze your app
while it's running,
use the log viewer
to monitor its logs.
Open the Command Palette by
selecting View, Find Command.
Type Cloud Code View
Logs and click on it.
This opens up the
Log Viewer, which
allows you to filter and
navigate the logs for your app.
In the Deployment section,
select Go Hello, World.
Now refresh your
app in the browser.
Come back to the Log Viewer
and click the Logs Refresh
button to see new logs.
You should see a new message
for the latest Get request.
So far, you've been
running your app locally.
Now it's time to push your
app to a remote cluster.
First, you'll need to create
a new Google Kubernetes Engine
cluster to deploy your app to.
Click on the Cloud
Code Kubernetes
icon in the Navigation bar.
This Kubernetes Explorer
makes Kubernetes development
easier by simplifying cluster
creation and management.
Hover over the
Kubernetes Explorer bar,
and click on the plus sign.
Select Create GKE Cluster.
In the Create Cluster Wizard,
select your Google Cloud
project.
You'll need to select some
properties for the cluster
you're going to launch, such
as the zone or region, cluster
name, and any other selections.
Click Create Cluster.
Cluster creation may
take a few minutes.
But once it's
created, your cluster
is listed within the
Kubernetes Explorer view.
Finally, let's deploy your
app to the new GKE cluster.
From the Cloud Code menu,
select Run on Kubernetes.
Confirm your newly
created cluster
as the context for
your deployment.
Confirm the default option
for your image registry.
Once your app is
successfully deployed,
you can launch it via the link
displayed in your Output panel.
Congratulations.
You've just created and run your
first Kubernetes app on GKE.
Don't forget to delete your
cluster using the GKE Explorer
to avoid any unwanted charges.
Just right click your cluster
and select Delete Cluster.
Want to try this out yourself?
Check out the interactive
tutorial linked
in the description below.
Make sure to subscribe
to the channel,
and stay tuned for more
Cloud Shell Editor videos.